un simbólico y polémico apretón de manos
el presidente Manuel macrón saludó al
príncipe heredero Mohamed Bin salman el
jueves por la noche Es la primera vez
que el Saudita es invitado a Francia
desde que fue acusado por los servicios
de inteligencia estadounidenses de
Ordenar el asesinato de Yamaha el
periodista fue asesinado y descuartizado
cuando realizaba una visita al consulado
Saudita en Estambul en 2018 acoger a
bins salman a pesar de estas acusaciones
es un hecho muy criticado por las ong
que evidenciaron su rechazo con una
acción legal
y la demanda que acabamos de presentar
hoy en París es algo que hemos estado
preparando durante dos años esperando a
que Mohamed Bin salman pisara territorio
francés para poder presentarla
la denuncia se refiere a la rendición de
cuentas cómo se supone que alguien en el
mundo va a creer que nuestros países son
los que defienden la democracia y los
Derechos Humanos ante este tipo de
comportamiento desvergonzado
desvergonzado beso al anillo de Mohamed
pins salman
una reunión diplomática destinada a
discutir los precios del petróleo
mientras Francia Busca proveedores
alternativos a Rusia sabemos que Arabia
Saudita tiene las mayores reservas de
petróleo del mundo y una quinta parte de
la reservas de gas Así que eso atrae a
mucha gente y están dispuestos a olvidar
la guerra en yemen el caso hacha y otras
violaciones de los Derechos Humanos en
Arabia Saudita el gobierno francés se
defendió diciendo que los temas de
Derechos Humanos estuvieron en la agenda
no se trata de cuestionar nuestro
compromiso con los Derechos Humanos
al igual que Francia Estados Unidos
también mantuvo conversaciones con
vincelman Joe biden se reunió con el
príncipe hace apenas dos semanas